all right and we are live the last word
with Lorca Neto and Eve artist returns
fresh off that Guardian con four-year
hiatus before I saw this man and all
he's got a birthday by the way so make
sure y'all give him a happy birthday to
my man E
this is his time to drink raise his
chalice good throw fat from strength my
man
Lodi Paz was going on in not much yet my
birthday was yesterday so that is true
so I am one more lap around the Sun
older and honestly like just kind of
still thinking back on the past week
that we had which was just absolute
crazy so we went to Guardian con which
we are gonna dig into first then we're
gonna kind of talk about the patch
changes that happened
I'm obviously everything that changed in
the game with the tribute hall the new
quest that we had and then just some
general things that are kind of out
there in the reddit world for destiny so
a couple things to talk about but
Guardian con gonna be our first big
topic so basically jumping right into it
I just kind of want to get your your
feel of just how was the experience it's
been four years since I've gone so
mine's kind of like a huge drastic
difference but what about you you've
been a little more fresh eyes on a trip
again yeah man I mean um listen man it's
always good to be around your brethren
and gamers and obviously this community
we've been talking about at length you
know what's been going on with Saint
Jude's so um I think the first thing off
the bat is definitely a fan of Orlando
as opposed to tranfer so let's just get
right to that right now
um shout out the Rose and Shingle Creek
whoo oh man that the island the
self-contained Leviathan it itself you
could put like a packs in there you can
for the ether you can put like all these
little conventions in there man but yeah
it's truly a spectacle and then
obviously you know us linking up you
know long overdue this is where this
thing started at so it's always good to
see the man's face he's doing well and
get now him out and about and seeing all
the content creators see both of us
together which is kind of kind of dope
you know saying and then
just so many standouts me so many people
who shot all the people who came up to
us man um what's your man name on
something monkey insane monkey that was
new here was that fire - yeah five team
Chad I mean just so many people that
just came to say yo I recognize you
Yvonne - so yo Cognito right like it
blew me away I was like hold on we here
for these babies just humbling like is
truly humbling and um you know the last
thing - is just like the content
creators and being I think everybody
being so accessible and no ego I mean
just a chilling wife that was that was
that was a good moment to fall out plays
cool guy I mean the list goes on and on
khakis everybody man it just shows you
when this communities together how much
fun it is and I gotta be honest with you
he like with Orlando with Rose and
Shingle I could see me doing this like
an annual thing man like it I love this
venue and the way it was handled so much
and now we can't call it cardi what is
it uh
GSX GGC X so what is it good is the
gaming community Expo I think gaming
community expo because it was just
Guardian things still definitely does me
focused definitely community people will
be there but they're changing the name
giving it a little broader appeal yeah
so I mean the last thing that just would
be um just the morning the coolest thing
was Bungie you know the accessibility I
mean just seeing you talk to all the
devs and and damage panel and Blake and
deeds right there and I got a chance to
talk to the the producer of the r18 you
know raids I mean interesting all she
was amazing you know just it words
cannot describe how accessible everybody
is how friendly is how and just it's for
gaming so I could go on gushing about
like we're gonna try and get pieces of
this thing for sure yeah like no I mean
for me it was the same way it was I mean
I went there to fanboy
that's pretty much the whole point of
what you do on some of these things
anyway whoa
fanboy meeting all the people the
Bullard streamers people and Twitter
artists that you met and get to actually
meet them all in person shake their
hands I have quite a bit of Arts which
I'll probably show on the stream here a
little bit amazing artists out there oh
my god oh macht what's my boy named
Marcus yes yeah Brian moves any solo
yeah so there are a lot of awesome
artists but then it's like yeah talking
to I got to talk to Bungie staff and
multiple different venues whether it was
at the bar at night I talked one guy's
ear off because there was like a key
line there was like a cue line to play
crucible for all the coins and stuff
they had and then the guy who is a
managing the the pins that you would
wager your game Bitcoin for when you
played gambit yeah he was like a
performance tester uh dude I was talking
to him about some of the most random
stuff just about the game and history
and like PlayStation 3 was like he'll
develop before and just like different
things like that I'm like I'm just
sitting I was like I could pick I could
talk to those people just asking
questions for a long time so you all I
saw is the fact that he just let me do
that for like 20 minutes probably just
talking to him like right by the line he
said they're at the table on the other
side just like chatting back and forth
was awesome yeah I met so many cool it's
like Jared one of the producers Lars
real quick got just like a half a minute
well he was busy as hell Ozzy jizz you
got to talk to each for half a second
which was cool that was that the Bungie
event mm-hmm what there's I mean Blake
battled met him he's one of the
producers Jared Berbick both of them I
met at night at the bar and they were
just like they were awesome just
chatting and I went up to talk and they
were just like and just like went
straight into it stuff they're excited
for and and I think that's one of the
biggest things I'm starting with a
Bungie people because that was kind of
where I spent a decent amount of time
but it was I could see you light up all
right every dev you were like kitty BK
teased or just like ask questions you
it's what I was watching this is awesome
cuz like I go to cause all the time yeah
I I am a little spoiled by it but to see
like you were radiating you were like
ready to dive into questions thought
process and I was like I let my man go
let me let me let the cheetah verse
they'll get work baby but it was like
from the Bungie
is not saying nobody else has this
feeling but from specifically the Bungie
people because they work here there but
their passion for the game their
excitement for what's to come
their feeling which they know how to
answer the questions when you're like oh
that hole Activision split and honestly
some of them said it right destiny
wouldn't be what it is without
Activision they wouldn't have got off
the ground they wouldn't have had the
backing to get there but at this point
going forward they have different ideas
so they have split so it's like you
can't just completely knock Activision
because these were a bankroll for a
while they were the producer on it they
were the distributor they got him on PC
stuff like that all happened so and they
were all really smart to just like
remind what's up and a lot of people cuz
there was some there was like a Q&A part
with us and be like hey good job on the
Activision split and when you sit there
and you talk to him individually later
they're like hey what would have
happened without it's like it's nice if
they're still like they learned a lot on
both ends it's just kind of different
ideas going forward so the band's they
are so so excited about what's the
common all of them like I talked to a
couple in like certain things they're
excited about like cross save huge thing
and the works like really excited for
new light like the influx of players and
some of the things they get to look
forward to with those pieces are like oh
man they're they're really pumped and
they all have like different pieces that
they're working on I talked to one about
like Armour 2.0 and stuff like that and
they're like dude you can't even I can't
tell you but yeah artifacts and and all
these systems that they're building and
this is like 1.0 of like their new new
world new RPG feel I mean it's enough
they just kind of want to build on top
of like systems once they get something
in place add a little more depth like
take the artifacts and make them
function make them do things and then
make them crazier later on so not gonna
talk to them just for the entire weekend
I just love Wow oh yeah because again I
you know and we got I want to get I want
to state another point you know in
reference to that because there was that
cool thing that I actually sent you to
the wrong conference hall for yeah you
were in like the what was the way it was
talking
sir our and whisper yeah yeah the walk
through for that right along so I was in
one and it was like deej it was your boy
Blake it was Lars
it was Pinole and I forgot hungers name
who's the producer of the agency or else
again
so I'm in Chelsea so basically it was
literally like talking about a farm
talking about expansions from going from
ceases to expansions what they did wrong
what they did right of what can you can
improve so I'm gonna be honest these
type of things I've gone to cons of
going to conventions it's never
interactive it's usually it's just you
know one person you know them dictating
and throwing out things against the wall
kind of thing generally that's how that
kind of stuff go I gotta give these
credits out a conversation with DJ
through it I mean as eat when you saw
when we got there there was a mic
literally in the middle of this little
mini auditorium and they allowing the
fan base to come right up and and and
literally like they were on the firing
squad but it wasn't like disrespectful
or anything like that you know it was it
was handled very well I wish it was a
little bit more time because we because
you know I was like hold on like one one
side cuz I said this the other night on
chat before I go for it if you are ever
in one of these situations whether it's
a random conference whether it's like
you're meeting like there's a medication
talking on stage and it's when you're
like hey I want to go ask these people
question have your act together make it
shortened to the point it's okay to
think oh I don't need your friggin life
story and like get to the point because
oh my god people up there talking for
like five minutes
we're like 1996 destiny was the first
game that I ever and my firstborn child
and this in that and turn with me to
Ecclesiastes chapter four verse five I'm
like bro could you get to the quick like
there's a line of people here yeah
trying to ask and interact with Bungie
and literally on the teleprompter
there's three things yeah what do we do
right what do you know can we improve it
maybe I've come with the third one was
one was like you know how was your like
the change of seasons or something like
that what go in
go out do you did I like to think
all the people they made it possible and
yeah I'm like I like my mom my dad was
going like there were a couple of those
and some were a little quicker than
others but all the ones ahead of us were
pretty damn long when I got in the room
with you and I don't know how before I
got there but but yeah me as you said I
feel like it's like that's a rare thing
to have the interactivity and it was
like relatively smaller space I mean you
put Bungie on a stage with it like you
know Hall H or something like some crazy
out of this room it's gonna be a little
nuts and there probably somebody might
try and get it but everybody at Guardian
Con is so passionate they're willing to
travel to buy the con like the ticket to
get in there so there's a passion about
the game so there's a little respect for
it too so they're not gonna be leaving
your game sucks so I'm like run away
it's like no one money to be in there to
me that much of a turd so yeah and I
just wanna I want to finish the point in
his sense that um when I spoke to DJ's
cuz basically deej is the one who said
um you know he's responsible for setting
that whole thing up so I just said look
I want to give you guys credit because
at the end of the day the way I looked
at it is like this you know they didn't
necessarily have to do that type of a
setup and my feeling is okay will you do
that kind of thing you risk firing squad
mentality you know I'm saying you risk
being you know people with an egg with
negative energy towards you and I said
look you know maybe from next time you
might wanna one put a time limit to you
know just basically have a little bit
more structure with it because I was
just nervous for them that people might
try to attack but thankfully people did
it was a company but I complained here
and there but minor things but I felt no
one was like really on the attack what
did you feel overall with the way that
was handled with Q&A part I thought it
was good I got in there late but when I
did get in there it was for what I
listen to life stories and stuff aside
that's like a whole separate thing I
think one of the things especially too
when you get up in that situation was
one thing you and I both said that we
would have done quicker is the like make
it short but thank them
first thing I came out think cuz the
reason they're with maybe two people who
did it yeah and they did well that I
heard not a lot I would say said if we
gonna say maybe twelve people went up to
two three started off with thank you for
this game and changed my life it's the
reason why I'm here in the community
that you got to set it off top people
and I'm saying so yeah I agree yeah that
was that was one that we were both
sitting there like kind of whispering
lie and be like dude like come on like
yeah but overall like when they would
talk they would just you know somebody
would say it's like well hey it's like
you know when it comes to seasons these
things happen and this and that and the
other and they'd be like all right well
let's go back to this it's like what
about you know say strikes or something
currently what would you like and they
really would turn around and be like
they listen they turned out they asked
them very specific questions what they
can look for for feedback and I mean you
have to take all of those things with a
grain of salt but when they can sit
there and ask just some butt pluck
someone from the community and just be
like how do you feel about this I mean
that's a true random poll and they were
really like listening digging in for
questions like and they weren't just
like talking down to him they were
really honest answers it was yes they
wore the spot bro that that to meet
again old I'm know me you we go back and
forth of certain things when I agree to
disagree but I could never take that
away from Bungie that is truly putting
yourself in the arms of your community
and saying hey I want this type of
feedback and it'll to me it started when
I seen that transformation on the way
back to the summit's because I said
that's unique I've never seen other
games they fly fly you into the studio
you know you're good at this you're
great at this let's get your feedback
and let's help let's work side by side
with the developers who creating each
individual part of the game amazing
amazing and truly again cannot salute
them enough man but uh yeah was so much
con to talk about like what else sounds
like so right after that one we'll just
kind of go in order of what pops in my
head because it's all in place the water
team shot so well yeah we were front
room for fire team Chet if you look at
the picture the destined through
there were blurry in the background but
in the front row we're in there yes
shadows a monkey he was right behind and
that was cool like we sat down and like
I was wearing I had shirts made that had
my logo on it said he bond to sand it
worked as like for introductions for me
pretty well so everybody could kind of
put the cheetah and the name to my face
which worked
nice but when like I was wearing the
shirt we were in like waiting for fire
team chat I was talking to a couple of
people because the bunch of guys were
still there and then I sat down as like
ebon tiss and I was like he's like I saw
the shirt but I wasn't sure but then I
heard the voice and I was like hope
there it is but it was like he even said
he's like dude I forgot the picture and
honestly I did that for some and I went
back for some pictures later but as well
but for some of them like if you sit
there and you just get into a
conversation you're talking for real
it's not just like hey let me get a
selfie it's like hey look it's like when
we talked about this you get into
conversation trade words back and forth
those are the cooler ones for me it's
just like when I heard the wrong there
was like there was an actor I forget who
and I have no idea I'll probably never
remember cuz I don't remember the story
but they were just like you know can I
get a picture with you and they're like
no but I'll talk with you I'll shake
your hand anything like that cuz like
what's a picture got in it or do you
want to sit there and talk to this
person that you've like wondered about
meeting forever and actually have a
conversation it's like those moments are
a lot of the cooler ones for me cuz like
the pictures were cool but like the
conversations that I had are the ones
that I saw that stuck with me more so I
just watched you yeah elevate with
absolutely hilarious
um from media it's a competition I am
picture guy I'm not gonna lie I like
movements I like um to take advantage of
but of course I you know I like that's
the last word we gotta talk you know
this of course I'm gonna have discussion
I won fanboy moment that I didn't expect
you laughed at me briefly um to what was
Paul tastic yes I never thought I would
meet him he's very I mean I could sit if
he hasn't been either he wrote in his
article about he's never been the
guardian Condon yeah that surprised me
that was his first um and again I saw
him when I think I saw very quickly when
we first met up but he was like doing
stuff and I was like hang on father ah
man he's moving around you know I might
think is I don't like to bother people
like
completely in groups in their own
element got it but when we're at our
five team chat which is Luke to those
guys so look the friend being back up
there like all the times sure that it
was all that show was great it made you
realize how special she and I missed my
boy Sean Finegan - that's not a
shout-out to us Steven writings he was
awesome and I believe the other guys
saying was just Nick doesn't control
Teddy Teddy salute Eddie
but back to taxi home yeah man like so
he's there on the opposite side first
we're there
we're all having a good time enjoying
the content talking destiny ranking
stuff a lot of community interaction
it's over and he's like he's there I'm
my friend I got I got I gotta go holla
he does it I got it I'm kidding the
coolest dude yeah the humblest do like I
don't know what people have in their
mind about him maybe cuz their articles
if a lot of people don't agree with the
article they automatically vilify you
like I'm the type of person and I told
this to him that is that your headline
his headlines are so good but if you
don't you can get caught up in but you
have to read the article and a lot of
times it literally you think about what
you gonna say to him coming up what you
think the article is gonna be coming
into it and then you read and you like
she's actually really valid is very
honest here and do amazing amazing
discussion um shadow 7eo Metro um the
other person for me surprisingly this is
like the the crucible in me was mercury
mercury I'm a fanboy I'm a fan but I'm
the dude that's on the crucible playbook
reddit looking at the matter looking
what's going on let you know right now
shot them he's got a dope one up right
now by air until great roles and what's
funny is before you put up his like I
hesitated on putting this up because I
didn't want to draw too much apart like
steam as one of my secret weapons I
think what you talk about this for the
community but the other part is he's
such a scientist with everything you
know what stats with rolls with lenses
with views with plus/minus is arrange
trap I mean the guy is a beast and the
work that he puts with these
spreadsheets so you can
her playstyle what she want to run away
and time to kill this up tremendous
Berkeley's was a highlight for me man we
got that was that I forgot we was at
that other bar the other spot inside the
Leviathan Rosen chic there's so many
balls you don't have to leave this place
no you can literally stay there the
whole time
yeah so shout out to him great
discussions and speaking of scientists
of course the amazing Fallout plays come
on pin him like seven times so many
times that sounds like hey hey hey hey
like I finally got a picture with I
bumped it in him like seven times and
finally got a picture like the lat I was
like somehow dude I've not got a picture
with you he's like what and I'm like
hadn't happened yet he's like alright
you know I ended up getting a picture
with because a few of the people he was
running with I got a picture with him
Cammie cakes drew ski and cool get all
in the same picture right there towards
the end though yep all four of those
guys and they're just they were all like
every one of those guys nicest can be
like drew ski went out to the summit
recently very good guy Morris like no
fallout cool guy literally last week
lives on the name in every way just dude
what's up man how's it going cool guy is
cool guy cool guys the cool we just say
he is the coolest guy like this is cool
guy definitely sure his namesake and
then kami cakes man that dude has a
beard that puts anything I've ever got
shame my god it's late it'd be like
scratching my chest down here that is
some kind of some growth work right
there but not mmm
dude don't know and just like all of so
many cool people like in the whole
community I mean I could like the list
to go down it's like meaning biph like I
mean it's like by the way for one
respect to dado cuz his line is insane
talks to them all spends the time and
even before it's like they were like
working on closing it down he spent like
an extra forever talking to as many
people as he could grow I mean and then
eat and he had to be laid up donut
underneath the table yeah byph was doing
the same thing wife was at his booth the
whole time he's just like hey how's it
going
grabs a bite and comes back grabs
another bite and he's just like trying
just out of starvation cuz his line
never stopped
never
two days like the booth that he had just
constant but he was taking off and we
were honestly like I was like in line I
was gonna go pop over and out like cuz
he was pretty close to his line was
where some of the Bungie people were and
then low note was always around there
shot the logo say no to rage of course
talked to him a couple times but like
his line wasn't moving that fast and I
come back and you're like it's not going
that fast but it's like you watch and
byph was like taking time having real
discussions like everybody listen nobody
can't tell me nothing about bye for now
as far as being true blue that man for
as high profile as he is as a content
creator he literally gives each and
every person like you said he that
personal attention
and he will extend the be conversations
like he's not trying to just do it and
then get you out of it like he's really
building with you you know I'm saying
and it just you feel it like it's just
oh my so many shots I want to give him
to come myelin games that's my homie -
they like myelin games a lot of respect
bro we got a chance to chop it up a lot
during that entire you know and I'm
saying trip and um so much respect man
we got to talk about the whole Bungie
thing that um shout out I didn't think
I'd meet him was when I wasn't around
you em - guy was I was shocked I loved
him later at the bar didn't introduce
myself it was not the right time but I
thought oh yeah - was was so funny
hilarious of course my personal homey
khakis HD you know I actually caught him
later
oh good that's what I'm talking like the
last morning of birthday or something
walking by and then walking back and I
saw him over there breakfast then just
like like leaned over the wall in the
buffet area just like cactus he's like
what up you bond has he's like oh what's
up so he was having breakfast and stuff
hey yo cactus is the man yo shout out
there hip shadow shout out to all men at
arms we got a chance to build it with
Meehan Milan so UFC fight that was kind
of dough we challenges content creators
really lit me I mean the list goes on
man I mean shout out to true Vanguard I
got the chance to tease him would fall
out who's kind of funny
yeah oh
oh so many men went through Vanguard for
a while
ultra nice like people were walking up
elite hey can I get a picture
hey what's up man hey true Vanguard like
he's pretty recognizable and I was just
literally like the one time I stood line
on crucible and we'll get to some of the
logistics here in a little bit but
instead of line of car I just sat there
and just chatted with him for a little
bit really nice guy
Evangeline towards the end was like all
right well I'd be remiss if I didn't get
a picture cuz I talked to him the whole
time we went through line and then the
best part was for crucible I played
against him and got smoked absolutely
destroyed so yeah I will
trying to think of anybody else like cuz
there's so many go down throw me a value
like shout out to all of them for broke
four million dollars you into st. Jude's
four million was the over over for is
the final if it's even a final yet I
don't know when they couldn't finish it
up believable so crazy like that number
is awesome awesome to see so four
million fully complete for that one
they're still probably getting a little
more little trickle in over the rest of
the month so crazy brave I think well
last year was like two seven and they
were going for three and that's nine so
they blew that away
mmm-hmm so get valiant broman not gonna
say anything about it but if you go to
Guardian gone go to the rare drop Awards
the last night events I can't say what
happens bad etiquette of attendance but
all I can say is I laughed my butt off
yo I was it was it was very entertaining
so one of those things you're not quite
sure but very very well done and then a
lot of people there I mean there were
people like dr. Lupo was there you had
yeah you know just a lot of people I
actually ran into Lupo in the lobby of
the hotel just before you like to and
just as nice as you could expect so all
in all very very late I'm still gonna
not hit everybody that I'm thinking of
right now I know we definitely miss
people there's no there was just that
mungus oh it was one that I can't forget
cuz she's coming on next week the Queen
right we got the
we got Red Queen an awesome streamer she
was just insanely nice locked up we were
taught started talking to her nicest
lady like came up started talking to us
about streaming and like mentioned a
podcast and she was like podcasts like
it is funny to watch because some people
make they do content are they stream but
sometimes they don't just get to you
know kind of just chatted up about
destiny and like the podcast is
something some people are just like like
hell yeah like coz I mean when like cool
guy was on here it's like anybody we've
had on here it's like just they enjoy
talking about it and you know they get
off on tangents cuz it's just a
different forum I mean the podcast is a
different thing and yeah it's like she
was really excited so she we confirmed
she is good for next week so she will be
here I'm pumped for that one she may be
more excited than us I think I'm not for
real I was like yeah we thrill it was
fun yeah just to see I think what it is
to other you nailed that I think is as a
content creators them being content
creators like even me coming you know on
the last word you know I don't be here
it's not that there's a sense relieved
just okay I can just talk about destiny
you know say like I don't have to
necessarily be working at doing any you
know say and I think they enjoy that you
know say it is there's something to be
said know me and yeah just to see you
know her enjoyment and she was just so
cool like all the way through so yeah
very thankful that uh she reached out
and yeah we definitely excited to have
her on yeah so she was lucky enough to
get to go to the summit so she's up
there Wow
getting the sneak so jealous of course
but sadly in a good way so for sure wow
that's like that's the dream is to get
like the tap on the shoulder get the
call right I can hang up the hell the
channel like there's no more videos I
did it yes that's that's that's the
mecca right there so those who did get
to go so no you know of a couple but I'm
sure there's plenty who went up there
but yeah she is gonna be coming and then
just as
I'm trying I'm trying to think of
anybody else before we kind of move on
and I know that section so many yeah say
an older age that's not bumped into him
to like three or four times in the Red
Queen I think it's her husband to
second-to-last when we met him he was
right there next door to so he was
really cool
yes and then just Twitter has been like
blowing up for follows and tweets and
things so just the feet of Guardian
Cantus I will say for those who didn't
go I saw seeing would be like a mutant
Guardian con man it's just killing me
it's just cuz it hurts not being there
it's that to beat it is really yeah if
you can find a way to get there so let's
talk about Rosen Shingle we gotta talk
about resort man man you just livin on a
cruise ship on land like let's just talk
about it sir it's the Leviathan that
it's the Leviathan of all places
opulence it is it is it is literally a
resort it's beautiful it's our then the
logistics it's not far from the actual
the hotel you know it's literally again
this self-contained we need island on
land it is it that you have access to it
and their stores inside this multitude
of restaurants there's multitude of
convention halls the rooms are
absolutely gorgeous the pool area is
amazing I mean what else can I say I
mean just but even before you get into
Guardian con and I don't know if you saw
the footage I they like just the whole
arcade thing that they had set up
leading orchid Oh mint so amazing and to
think we didn't even go to that other
side with technically ten o card was
going on yeah didn't even look in there
that's another separate part of the
Leviathan we ever built you know it's
truly a man like the UM the buffet area
that like for the breakfast in the
morning you know when you come down I
mean you know for the brothers trying
get the A's or get that generally
fathers Amy I mean no problem with that
is easy but not all jokes aside it's
like a resort it's it's just
all-inclusive is this
everything you want is there like that's
how amazing is what now for you you know
like how was it like now this year first
both offer spring be your first
experience as well yeah I mean the
resort was like ultra nice I mean you
take cruise ship that has like
restaurants you have like shops and
stuff like bet you have the pools you
have like late-night food if you need it
from that weird pizza joint but the bars
that are open the burgers out of the
Dead oh he said I saw y'all chalices yes
the Mexican restaurant in there called
me Casa taqueria tequila has giant
margaritas the size of her head they're
huge fishbowl looking things they're
ginormous they weren't that strong sadly
because I had to be could you imagine if
they was really laid there be a lot of
men guardians in it yeah so that I will
say when it came to and nothing against
the waitstaff they were they probably
like well after we all left probably
just were like I'm done I'm dead leave
me alone but the few days that people
were there they were strapped
unfortunately they were just thin like
weights were getting a little long
because they had way too much more than
they ever expected like there's no way
cuz if you have like a convention
somewhere I'm sure you take people in
and they're like hey let's go out to eat
at restaurants and stuff like that but
as everything was there and a lot of
people from you know the commute it's
like well it's a resort it's all here
when you turn and you have like a
thousand people show up in the
restaurant area and you have like
headwaters lounge the bar and then you
have the burger place and you have
Mikasa and it is absolutely packed for
hours and hours and like more place to
sit and wait and they're just like it's
just a little defense in the defense he
you're completely right right but in
their defense I I think they truly
didn't understand the scope no I don't
think really gonna have what Guardian
Khan was yeah they didn't really know so
they didn't understand it them
restaurants better be open all all the
time and people gonna be constant going
back and forth the bars okay I remember
one of those spots like they were
supposed to close up maybe like 10 or 11
they stood to like one - you don't say
almost 2:30 I know yeah I seen them
having to go get other people who were
managerial just trying to help out just
at the bar I
part of me felt bags I was like may like
oh yeah they don't know they don't know
what this is right now and these are big
bigger venues I was like these are not
like small little rinky-dink bars small
orange notif fully for the most part
functional restaurants and things that
can operate independently and for us to
have I mean us being you know Guardian
fans like to have this place packed to
the brim moving and shaking all the time
like I think next year they'll know
they'll understand that then I have to
get the part time is on get a little bit
more fully staffed at Canada and and she
all man how cheap oh I mean let's be
real funny yes what if you look up that
place normally yeah they'll have more
staff next year for sure but if you look
up the room rates normally we got a few
more than 50% off by going through
Guardian Khan and honestly like what my
wife and I did we stayed for a couple
extra days and as long as you link it to
your guardian con days it's the same
rate the whole time so that's why we
stayed longer it was like couple more
days and Resort in Orlando go do like
some fun stuff for a couple days so hell
yeah so that was why it was like worth
the extra days to now apparently there's
like um you want to get there the day
before if not like yes a day and a half
before like the night of like say it
starts on Saturday next here you want to
get there like Thursday night because
you want to be able to get there
settle in hang out on Friday casually be
around go pick up your badge that thing
pick up your yeah get that really ahead
of time yeah that way on the day I mean
if you can yeah I'm not shaming you I
know that was know yeah so absolutely so
travel if you if there's like a noon
flight that gets you there at like four
or five or there's a 7 a.m. and get your
ass up out of bed and get there early
they will hold on to your bags and you
can take care of all your normal stuff
and kind of be there for the day and
check people and that's when like that's
what people will be setting up and
that's when you know like you know
somebody led to a slight rain and people
might be over at lunch when it's the
little quieter and it's not insane cuz
this next year it's gonna be Saturday
and Sunday both days are gonna be stupid
bananas so
because the Fertile cuz Saturday versus
Friday that was a different animal
oh yeah it's it's nine day it's nine
date it's level there's levels to this
so I have my opinions when it comes to
and again first time in the venue things
like that what are your thoughts on just
the con itself any logistical changes
that you would like to see whether it
was you know like I feel like I kept you
know either miss placing where the dam
keep the other stage was that I was like
where the hell oh it's finally all the
way back here like hey yeah just some of
the some things like that or signage of
like hey you could have a sign even in
front King of Kings coast like the stage
where yeah yeah well she was like these
are the times for this today like stuff
like that like any logistical things
that you would throw cuz you know I've
got my couple Oh bad pick up obviously
we just talking
um mini auditorium labeling like you
said you know because again the cook
that thing it's a shame because a lot of
these auditoriums have these cool panels
I mean very dope interactive informative
panels and you really don't want to miss
it some of them ago same time so you got
to make tough decisions so if they can
be more clear because I know everything
is kind of restricted to the app and
their little schedule but I think they
need to be a little bit more clear maybe
on the floor by having it's like you
said signs some type of bulletin board
hey this is what's going on at this time
here and so this way it's a little bit
more clear but again for me it's just -
or I look at it as them new to a venue
the venue new to them you know I think
these are in all fairness like very my
new logistical changes that can
literally be made and make things go a
thousand times smoother right so um yeah
that's literally all I got I mean oh I
know when that you got an hour tomorrow
I'm already gonna steal when the or
listen I know you and that thrilled
about II was not thrilled about the
location of won the gambit play area
where you play the game where the lines
were and then there's a second thing
where I'll shout out to the big show
Mahler we'd even talk about that no yeah
I thought it wasn't gonna hit everybody
yeah shout out to the big show Marla fro
who plays on eros
you know and um you know just a content
creators of stuff that were in the
Bungie dedicated era now they kind of
had it in the center of the convention
part and that I gotta agree with E at
first I wasn't easy being too hard a
monument because the problem now is the
lines for that gets so long it starts in
the center and then it starts to wrap
around other content creators so it's
like blocking body fits blocking other
people that you want to see it maybe
interact with so day logistically have
to do a little I think aesthetically it
looks nice in pictures that bungees in
the middle and they got the big sign and
all that but logistically the lines it's
it's it's crazy it's crazy to have it so
I would I stole that one for it yeah
that's one of my biggest ones was
because the main reason the lines were
bad so two sides you had the meet and
greets with the devs and then shout-out
to for one big show dude lives up to the
name he is massive when he walked by I
was like just like passing by and then
shout out some more lakorn donahoo I
ended up meeting was oh wow met her yeah
so it's knocking a friend for a little
bit and then talking to him and he was
over there like he was like hey let me
go say had a more or less like I've
never met her he's like you want me to
introduce you
he went over and started talking to her
he got into conversation then I was just
kind of like kind of went down and met
her and she was like really nice her
journey like she went through and stuff
she was ultra cool but she was only
supposed to be there for maybe like
three hours Wow on the days that she was
doing signing and stuff like that she
stayed for like 6 7 she was there so
much longer than she ever was so as to
be and she was talking to the fan she'd
see her like walk over get a picture in
front of him like taking everybody over
the lake she put hats off to that woman
because for one she was in heels most of
the time so her feet had to just be
awful death because my feet were hurting
in tennis shoes so I have facts
seriously man need better shoes
apparently need like walking squishing
oh absolutely like atoms in a moon shoe
I would be happy about it so that is one
side of the line people doing
meet-and-greets so there was like cool
guy and follow
Trucy and like they were they would pop
people in and out for like meet three
times in front so that's one line from
them then you had the devs and Moreland
Big Show on another side and this is one
side of the big giant box of bungee so
those lines are just like we're gonna go
spew everywhere on this side of the room
the other side which is probably the
worst line you're like hey they have a
lot of booths they were all PlayStation
so I suck at using controllers that's
been confirmed oh yeah it was I was like
yeah mouse and keyboard please no okay
you could play crucible in getting a
gambit coin a legit gambit coin which I
still in line the second day and barely
got in that thing which I'll explain in
a minute you get a came back Oien once
you get your coin you can wager said
coin in a gambit match if you win it you
keep your claim and you get a very
exclusive like Bungie pin which was
pretty damn legit but it wait do I had
to keep hearing about for me but yeah
then the other side was but if you lose
you lose the coin and especially
Saturday Saturday got to be Friday
wasn't as bad for whatever reason but
Saturday night
oh my god so they had there lying in
front of their booth was like cutoff at
like their little coops then they had
like a backup area and then they had a
second backup here well the fire
marshals were like what you can't stand
over here you're covering exit doors
things like that and then you couldn't
there was no place to wait to get in
line so shout out to the volunteers cuz
they had a hell of a job trying to
manage this thing but we were standing
in line and they're like you can't stand
here okay well we're do it how do we
wait in line Stan yeah where do we stand
where do we wait where do we like you
know cue to cue like where do we get in
the line for the line they had no say
finally they just were like come back
later like walk around the condo you
they were and people were just standing
around so that was while I was in LA
there was no organization for that as
bad as later he escaped yeah well and
then later on I went back because I was
like hey I'll try I was kind of close to
what I thought might be the front they
were empty in the line a little bit and
there was like a group of people that
have kind of like given a room to walk
but we were like basically a hug
chairs on the main stage as kind of
close and they're like maybe you stay
here like when this line empties up if
we get approval to fill it back up again
we'll pull they ended up not pulling
anybody who is standing up they pulled
everybody from the damn chairs who was
sitting down some people just could have
traded out in the chairs a lot of people
were waiting over there so like
everybody was just at that point people
lost their like started to lose it and
get pissed and they were just like so
the people who are like some because
they're like they had to stop the line
and make it so short so I guess
everybody behind it we're like hey go
take a seat or something like that we
got a short in the line so I guess they
thought they were pulling those people
had changed in and out I watched him
literally just yeah it was so Lacey the
gun the coin was really cool I wanted to
try and get another one to wager and I
just like I couldn't risk it so I just I
kept my coin and win but I was like the
logistics of all that and the thing
about that is like if they're gonna make
something exclusive at their booth which
is really cool like if you go to
Guardian Con Bungie specifically made
gambit coins and they're like legit they
got some weight to legit there's a legit
if they're gonna do that you got to
manage the lines but man they need like
so be I mean they brought more stations
than they ever have and they still
didn't even have remotely enough yeah I
mean it's it's interesting in here you
talk about cuz it's funny because like
me again going to eat the ribbon III is
tiny it's funny to hear it now because
it's like this like to be honest I this
is the main reason when I go to I don't
play games because I just don't have the
discipline you know I'm saying to be
able to really I mean just think about
this look I'll only waiting for bike oh
I know right okay so now you couple that
with everyone under the Sun trying to
play a game trying to get queued up and
then because of the way that area is set
up again they just didn't have the
experience to set it up correctly
whereas like I said it eats me up packs
whatever yeah it'll be a long one but
it's structured it's it goes a long run
past you know where you are how long
that wait
Yatta Yatta Yatta this is a lower play
they hear that story it you're talking
about but people are kind of like
getting snatched and randoms getting
inserted based on where they're sitting
and yeah they've got to clean it up and
I think a lot of it just comes down to
inexperience you know I'm saying new
venue
and like you said if they're gonna do
exclusive item you've got to get a more
efficient way oh and the big thing an
elephant in room let's be honest a lot
of these games went on too long I know
what I went to I got my butt whooped but
it was 45 to 200 that's how bad we lost
by the way I was number one on my side
you did you I had the most kills on my
team I had like 14 but I was playing
against true Vanguard and there was one
guy like two seats down who's another
unbroken late so I was playing against a
rough ridiculously stacked team against
the whole bunch of randoms and I was the
best of the randoms which in the world
of PvP not a great thing if I'm the best
I'm not gonna be pulling a team through
I'm not gonna go toe to toe with TV or
anything like that not even gonna try so
they've got is shorten those match times
like live if you want see this way it's
efficient to get people in you get
people out more people get a chance to
play those matches what a long way tool
yeah they were they're fine gesture but
just well yeah it was kind but it was
like I mean that's for the coin like
pump him through I know they're probably
cranked up the time so they didn't go
through too many coins yes
but I was like bring more mood people
faster and then the gambit lion I guess
it helped keep the game at line shorter
was like they gotta find some way to
manage that whether it's like game that
want like so that's the logistical piece
for next year I think for them is trying
to figure out how to manage all of their
stations and they had a ton I think they
had 772 maybe they had a lot they had a
ton of them and they still did not have
remotely enough so it was it was and it
was like it wouldn't be I wouldn't been
like oh it's curse well it's not a big
deal
oh I get an exclusive emote or I get an
exclusive coin and an emblem you of
course everybody's gonna lose their mind
over that stuff so I'm sure that they're
you paying brother yeah so but yeah
logistical pieces for like the bunch of
booth that aside like you literally I
woke up walk downstairs took the took
the elevator down got my breakfast
buffet with my wife then we'd go back up
to the room kind of get con ready to get
the backpack on also the security lines
those need fixed because when I went to
go get my dad to the first day there was
like hey do you have a badge go through
this security do you not have a bench go
way over here but I still had to go
through security and then get in a
second line after security to get my
badge put a box on the logistical teams
it's not that yeah we'll figure like
figure it out but it's like the badges
should be outside of security let me
make some calls we gotta get you on this
panel man we got it we got to get e he's
got it all lined up he's got making you
guys efficient right now he's driving
yes it's not that hard
no actually I'm sure there's an absolute
pain in the butt but after seeing it I
there definitely room for improvement
let's just say so but yeah like I'm good
as well make sure you got it all out one
of those things like you get to you're
in a traffic jam you get to the end
there's nothing there you're just
frustrated as hell yeah but yeah I was
like get up and then just literally walk
through the restaurant area down into
the down the stairs and into the
convention it's like and I don't have to
go outside in Florida in the summer ever
you don't have to go outside ever and if
you do it's probably gonna have a
swimsuit on you're going to the pool
exactly
amazing amazing I miss it already man
I'm ready to go back oh yeah like the
pool bar by the way they have like a
five they have like a berry it was like
a raspberry lemonade drink oh man dude
that's just like whether it's got
alcohol in it or not sit there and just
sip on that thing for a while it would
get it wasn't strong oh yeah like the
burgers were solid
my wife had like she got like so much
sushi the night she went on her own
because it was like would have been
Friday and Saturday Saturday night like
kind of last night when we were like a
little later in the Colin and seeing
stuff like she was like I just took her
she took herself at the sushi and I met
her and she was like I am so full like
she was legit headwaters lounge was
Lamar they just need like six more
bartenders in there like the whole day
I'd be next year for sure logistics
still have all yeah just this yeah just
like first experience for both sides of
it in the venue and the staff like next
year man is gonna be amazing so oh yeah
already ready yeah so we got wraps up
the world of Guardian con at least for
now but we'll be talking about that for
forever and I'm
knock it up a bit about with Red Queen
next week so mmm if I forgot your name
and I met you and I go back through
pictures like Siva Hyde like Siva I know
him he's here he helped like there's so
many people I haven't even mentioned yet
so forgot your name I'm pretty sure I
shouted most day out on Twitter or I'm
working on my Twitter tweets either way
so but next thing Bungie launches us
more stuff on Tuesday as I'm flying home
literally getting off the plane like Oh
something is live now yes and I hear
you've been playing a pretty good amount
yeah I've been busy
what do you guys land on the last
everything that like remember prior to
this you know I'm coming you know I got
the III thing I'm still in and out I'm
not really being able to dedicate a lot
of time and the last four days has been
nothing but that's there's been
Menagerie it's been catching up it's
finally getting my light level up you
know I was still really low light you
know so your boy getting up there now
and almost go 750 now I've been going
I've been going hard man I'm a it's been
it's been so much fun and he's in such a
good place yeah I'm flesh out the
carboxy he's actually playing some
combat some good runs in there you know
of course I'm still doing my armory I'm
doing enough um just the very things
that I want to shout out your boy arm
names and you got I saw you guys going
back and forth for like some tweets and
if it's almost I don't never say it's
bad thing to have a whole bunch of
sources to get but you literally have a
multitude of powerful gear sources yeah
of how you gonna get day that's why I
didn't take me long once I had enough
time to actually put into stuff because
between the dream and city and then Cal
it I mean burners bounties and and you
know crews moaning you daily it
literally just adds up you literally
getting in Graham after in Granite
Ingram so um it's it's interested in VR
my route is a lot o sources knows that
you could really get caught up but I've
been having a lot I mean I mean as far
as the exotic quest stuff I just started
the juju one I'm still working on that
get a lot of my stuff haven't the truth
I gotta get you jus I I'm so bad I know
Lumina you've got a great video right
now a Lumina like I've kind of right now
focusing more on the light and then so
that this way once I do the uh you know
the Lumina and all they're gonna drop at
seven fifty more say that's kind of
where I'm at with it but what have you
been focusing on I know you've been on
and you've been gone yeah so if you guys
have been on my twitch at some of you
guys are probably sleeping who catch my
late ones right now so first thing when
I got when I landed I was trying to my
Senate challenge because that thing
still seems to help people out so videos
yep still going so sinden was up those
are quick and easy to I've done him so
much happy to do those they're quick and
then it was jumping into bad juju
figuring out about the tribute hall
which there's she's have you touched the
tribute hall yet I have touched and I'm
mad that I did because I know that she's
amazed how what is so used it I told my
brother now of all people you'll play
more I told my brother was like for him
to grind out and get like the catalyst
for bad juju he'd probably never do it
she's like if I can walk him through the
cheese and he can do it he's probably
one of the few that like okay you you
and your crazy family life you'll use
the cheese cert use the G let use it
pseudo cuz I don't know how long it's
gonna be there and but I just jumped and
I was like alright so what is happening
and then I was like okay so this is
gonna take currencies how many things
can you earn okay so I had a decent
manner Planetary materials so I bought
some of the tributes some like one or
two I had our own chalice I am so broke
of materials III exact and this is
honestly for the people who wanted it
quick the content creators who want to
do reviews they paid out the rear end to
get that thing fast and then if they
wanted the catalyst they are broke mmm
let's call it what it is though let's
call it it's a material clean out that
is before shadow keep all you orders
this is literally coming for you because
I'm like yo five stuff so expensive and
then he's got like the spider hustle
going on where if you get one and it
doubles up and I was like bro the
good D mm-hmm so that is definitely
Bundy's way and I feel like they did
something like this before and I can't
remember what it was for but I feel like
they did like another inventory
clean-out or something like that to make
you spam than this yeah and I forget
what is for me yeah they're making you
spin planetary material shards and one
that I like probably I had like 40,000
brightness then down to 32 which is
still a ton so I'm not really arguing
and my shards are like 5,000 so I'm like
I'm okay but they need to have a
transfer system I need to get Sun you
need to send me alone really the shard
Bank which are like shards I don't you
there's not a lot of uses for shards
after a while
oh you don't match the work of hmm no I
think that's what yeah you don't Maximus
get a god that's my baby
it has to get oh shout out to you though
because we played I think before and we
was doing someone nightfall or something
and you were like dust off we do avoid a
burrow Kirkuk you like dust off your
crooked fan I'm like wow I was cooking
ages and mind you I had a guy roll one
from fallout mention shout these videos
and I'll show fall out my right he's
like oh my god that's the one out I
described in my video with the with the
charge that know all that and everything
so it's like backup plants an amazing
role suck it out there by the way we're
running the arms dealer strike FY know
how many shards hybrid has so oh yeah
yeah obscene 61 hi brain really
yeah I'm see anyway I don't even know
how you guys but anyway so we run an
Astra and I'm just like oh did I found
my new favorite legendary heavy like the
world by my mind you see I did not
realize how great after I got over my
you know I'm morning sleeper so I just
kind of just through all linear fusion
rifles away and I'm like I put them in
and they I got a shout out dude I cannot
let that thing out of my loadout
it is lit let me tell you how versatile
strikes in can be what I'm doing to
invaders is so easy like it is so in the
distance it's worthless leaflet like it
is it is pure and then I got the charge
time maxed out master worked out
it's got no back it got back up plan so
soon as you pull when I mean a firearm
all and I think I got snapshot on it is
the quick handling death-dealer and it's
powerful and I've got a running like two
or three scavenger perks and reserve
perk I got a dude I got like 21 shots
BAM it's it's disgusting so shout out to
you that is the new loadout right now
literally the only time I don't use it
no no but continues no you're good yeah
what I typically use that for is the
arms-dealer nightfall and that's what I
took you through it with and like yeah I
was like the boss was dead before we got
it before we got up the elevator like
see ya tanks die in three shots I mean
that's I heard that thing enough with a
void burn like that is the way to do
that one oh I'm roll away not a lot but
I have some moments no solo cuts a man
he's the man for par five real quick um
yeah I'll tell you right quick where's
my baby yet crooked bang yeah so backup
plan snapshot sights and then I have a
boss back on it and I got a charge time
or master work role that's that's pretty
there's two other's roles in there you
don't even need to Sam that's all you
need to say so serious bro and it excuse
me and enhance battery if I want our
liquid coils with the option if I want
to rip it's ridiculous let me just pick
out all the perks that I want I'm gonna
go what's that on one yeah that's a
pretty amazing roll it sounds like so
but if you ever want to run like this
week the arms dealer if you want to get
sure I want a solo at nightfall thing
you just stir it up so I got to do it to
one of those tribes attributes somebody
well there's an eyeful so the tributes
there's a
hundred thousand so I'll get to that one
in a second there's one called high
roller that one nearly broke me but I
finished it yesterday thank God that
video will go up some point okay soon
because it's useful this week and then
the other one is finishing night falls
with using calcium to Upton's our armor
everything in the tribute hall is using
Callas named weapons and armor the more
you wear outside of exotics which you
can use like some callous ones like kind
of problem with this a curious and then
bad juju technically accounted for what
I did so that really all bad juju works
as well which was a big one
shout out to vagabond Oh with the sub
for six months in the streets I
appreciate it so but every single thing
in the tribute hall is related to calais
themed arm and weapons so that's from
Leviathan raid sorrow or the Omni land
armor so the menagerie armor so you
can't go through and just run menagerie
five times and pick yourself at a set
well then you'd at least have the armor
weapons as well you need to be using one
of each for the high-roller you have to
have a full load out that's a hard one
and I did in Soul ice with man I'm and
nearly broke my head like so
no like if anybody's been watching my
streams like when I've been working on
this thing that my outtakes are gonna be
as long as my whole entire nightfall run
there are so many deaths that I've had
but what I ended up doing because
usually what I'll need is I need some
way to deal with ARC mm for strikes
because if you go match game matching
shields is important but you have to run
something from I don't have much from
the raids so I had to run anything from
Calais and there's not a lot of options
so I have fixed odds which is the new
heavy machine gun which is solar and
then I have beloved which is the solar
sniper and then I had bad juju which
counted thank God and then armor was
just literally five pieces it didn't
matter what the hell or still which I
need you random thought I need you added
throne this weekend I got some weird
yeah I got whatever it comes back
because next week let me know because
I got some weird um eat about me talking
about do that
yeah the rare one yes I was like you can
do a raid or shatter thrown for that one
shot it thrown with it with the master
but yeah the idea on the tribute hall is
you'll go through you walk up you talk
to him and then either you're there
about 15 that you can earn and of the
basic ones he gives you if you have some
materials you could probably buy two and
get your gun you need 18 total get bad
juju now if you go through and spend
time and earn it earn all the trimmings
that's 15 so you would be really close
you wouldn't have to spend that much and
then you could probably buy like one or
two and be good to go if you want to get
the catalyst it takes 45 whoa
so that's the hard one but when it comes
to the tributes that you earned
everything is related to the cows themed
weapons are or whether it's like getting
infamy while wearing those things
getting Guardian kills while doing those
things while getting invader kills while
killing enemies in gambit while killing
enemies and strikes it's all while using
gambit themed weapons and armor and the
more pieces you wear the more progress
you make I get it I just feel it needs
to be a little bit more clear I felt you
for sure yeah like my thing is like okay
I like the idea of what they're trying
to do I don't like that if you're not
cuz I gotta be honest on PC I have not
read it a lot right I'm not as just what
is it but it's big and it just kind of
sucks that alright yeah if I play
menagerie I gotta I guess I can slow
grind and get a piece here and a piece
there but takes time you know I'm saying
and then especially now the chess thing
is out the tres leches and out that's a
wrap so it's just like nice like I
really traffic they really want you to
go into these raids like they really
want you to do all of them and I'm just
like oh this is gonna be a slog man I
mean I'm out to get into LF jesus
something sorry I'm a little I guess
this is weird cuz I like raiding but I
just wish I had other options that
weren't so tied to everything raiding
with a set of armor and you know and
stuff not being clear I just wish with
other things I can wear as well it was
just I'm alone in the middle with that
and then the material stuff I'm just put
it pretty much at
I'm complaining there's everything I
don't have they're telling me to do like
I don't have materials you got to have a
thousand hey keep coming back to Calais
and get a discount you know two percent
discount
like what you see so you can have a
discount if you have like depends on
there is kind of a glitch with the
bounties I've seen some people say they
got 12% in a day if you do for bounties
on phone all three characters you can
have that done in like a week but even
if you do one character it's 80% if you
do four bounties a day and that's
literally all you do some are looking
literally get kills get precision kills
and strikes they're pretty easy bounties
the gambit one I think does somewhat
time consuming but you can have that
done by the end of the month and then
you still have all of August to do this
so you could have your discount
completely done and that would take your
wants from like the planning service
well I'm just saying like Planetary
materials is twin 2034 there's 110 120
130 140 150 you add all those up you are
talking about like 650 planetary
materials right now that's a ton but if
you're taking an 80% discount of that
number it might be like a hundred and
it's not gonna be that many and you can
get thirty planet serial 30 planetary
materials a day by doing daily bounties
on a planet so those are not that hard
to earn if you just want to go do some
quick bounties on a planet so oh but
like if you like if you want bad you do
down yeah you're gonna pay out the
absolute but for it yeah but don't you
can wait it's fine
this rule I know how much this kills my
soul you know much I love bad you don't
realize it's right juju is like one of
my first babies like that's : that's
that's why there is exactly why they put
it there Bungie they're thinking what
does that twit the the gift like the guy
who's thinking but yeah I'm gonna wipe
out all your stuff yeah at this fast or
for those patient folks you can wait get
that discount and it's gonna cost you
like you know little pennies not much
this is just pain I'll go into that
triumph and I see that box for my juju
and I can't have my juju mat is
bothering it there's no effective way to
get materials with
oh it's pain do some days go check out
what the exchange rate is it spider
spider I'll watch the video Oh trust me
I'll watch your video sir I watch all
the tricks did all of that and part of
me is kicking myself I didn't I should
have not started it I would have
completely done this cheats but I did I
would have so done the cheese like you
have no idea how I wouldn't get out of
this slog is just a material slog right
now look at me right I see you guys
running around my baby just sorry yeah I
don't have the catalyst that'll be a
while but long as you got him and that's
the gun and I heard it's nice man so
yeah it's pretty solid I think I don't I
didn't test it but I think cross was
saying in PvE P the damage gets up to
like almost a 50% boost but that it is
not a PvP gun it is straight up not it's
a pulse rifle ranges only okay might go
figure we'll probably out shoot it every
time but in PvE that is where that gun
is going to shine because killing
enemies especially low to medium level
they die and you instant refill your
clip or no reserves now the the the buff
works a little different it's string of
curses it stacks up to five but while
that stack is there the higher the stack
for each kill the more super energy you
earn and the gun are already thinking of
the builds in my home more than the
damage boost is up to basically 200% so
take a gun and double your damage if you
have that five stacker now the thing
about that is you can't like you can
kill five enemies and then if you shoot
the boss you'll be out of the shtetl
buffle go in like four seconds it goes
always already quick and I think the
catalyst extends it by like a second so
so basically you left the only like mini
weak to it is that you're not gonna use
it to DP up you're not gonna DPS boss
now but clear everybody super or yeah
and you and build that super and then if
long as you have a good energy that
that's where outbreak will still have
the boss DPS thing but for you
versatility juju man you throw some
super mods in there I'm already thinking
about maybe the nazarenko now I know why
skull of daya on a car I got that could
you imagine
I got a yeah mm-hmm so five seconds with
the catalyst three point five six
without the elevator of doing video
frame math but yeah shoutout to max of
pH just running around getting materials
is killing me thank you max be a thank
you that's all I'm saying do something
man give me some other options get some
stuff then hustlin would spider every
five minutes and see what what score no
him anyway moving moving alone I'm bad
cuz that's the big thing is if you want
it fast you're gonna pay out the butt
for it if you are patient and can work
on your discount it's not gonna be that
bad if you just do a few daily bounties
and stuff for materials by the time you
get the full discount like them even if
you do it like for bounties a day on one
character they go work on some planetary
materials by the time you have the full
discount like three weeks from now
you're gonna have enough materials so
but anywho what else we got so tribute
hall is actually really cool as well did
I want to shout that out and because
it's basically a firing range yeah
that's one thing is you start like
unlocking the tributes you can spawn the
tributes and they're just enemies that
spawn over and over and over and they
don't attack you so you can check damage
numbers see what is in there it's like
string of curses like one stack okay
what's this number one - what's that
number one two three what's that number
and I figured out like just in there by
myself I was like okay it's a 200% boost
at five it's like twenty percent extra
damage per stack so I was sitting there
doing like the the damage math right
there just because I have a firing range
for a change so it's nice so that was
really nice and for people like fallout
I was he's like they're enemies in the
tribute hall was like yeah it's like
enjoy your science and research and he
was like oh yeah he had a different word
for it but it was like hell yeah yeah
now you're still four Guardians private
matches work but in PvP PvE testing like
when you almost see like as across be
like alright so we're gonna go shoot
Greg and I can just shoot a dude I love
that dude yes I was like it helps like a
fire everybody has asked for some type
of fire
in testing range and this house managed
to put it the tribunal that's what it is
outside of all the last actions that you
put in so lumina happened while right
before we left so we haven't actually
talked about that either yeah so
Lumina hanging CEO year of hand cannons
all the hand cannons Oh Polly but hey we
got a pulse rifle in a damn good one so
wait a way to counter it
but Lumina so they were Dylan and Cosmo
or tweeting out and be like hey who can
figure out the fun combo in PvP mm-hmm
Lumina shooting someone using Sturm with
stacked bullets is a 195 shot it's a one
hit Wow Wow yeah that's the ultimate
support weapon actually okay you run you
know use that drink okay get a couple
kills load that thing up with ammo okay
hit me with this bam bam that says
literally if you're good you can stack
it so I mean you and loom enough for
hills it heals the other person it gives
both of you the buff so you damage it is
a it's a very good support weapon so if
you have somebody who's maybe not hey
I'm not so good at hitting those crits
like can you like hipfire the blob that
auto tracks like insanity for me yeah
you probably can do that like for my
brother with a hand cannon stick him
with that and he's like hey I can
finally play like some type like he
wants to play a tank which I still don't
have a way for him to do that with a
Titan but if you can hold a shield turn
if he can like use his Lumina turn
around above us and then hold a wall
shield and then he's given us extra
engage like that yes like yeah that's a
way to have a completely different build
so like go there they're they're
starting to toe the line of light
different functions of guns not just
everything doing damage so that's
probably one of lakes lumen is probably
not gonna be like amazing for anything
specifically support and can be kind of
cool but just then they're getting into
these ideas of like support classes and
different function in a group that is
and I see like the RPG elements are
starting to circle it and I cannot wait
mm-hmm dude I mean living no they like
that's just what it is right it's to me
D to we see the experiment two phases
start right we see them laying the
ground
for what d3 is gonna eventually be and
when we were at Guardian Con they
couldn't wait did you could see them
gushy would love to tell you but they
know they can't pay big if you know like
I know armor to fun I was gonna be crazy
you know it's got so much things man
like this sitting on and again it's just
great to see the the creative process
and them actually we you know what we
knew it was on though we watch the
screen we saw the energy without with
with Luke and Mark but album Activision
air and when they finally used Bungie
and the word MMO synonymous with each
other they were always scared to make
that connection now they're saying it
now we're gonna get those in-depth
things ah you can feel it man you give
any human err and these type of things
are all just dipping their foot in the
water seeing what works you know
tweaking it's gonna happen it's gonna
happen is there's no doubt my buddy this
is great stuff to see true support class
kind of stuff those type of our RPG
tropes love it and even what Dano
sitting there and said it's like this
one dude kept buffing me I was just
mowing dudes or the pulse outlaw rampage
just like just like buff the mowing them
down knowing about like the support
class and crucible like if you can get a
couple of these and go [ __ ] be like man
I got a couple bullets let's go hit it
once like following down it's already
getting let me give you one like I was
thinking about that aluminum right think
there's a very underrated um exotic
thing song okay there's a greater one
it's the UM I stepped it like a vampire
vest oh man look at my uh it's the one
warlock he put the riff down and you can
see sanguine alchemy oh you can see if
there's stuff you can see basically it's
radar for your entire team but it's a
short-range but it's there yeah yeah it
but it's pretty effective man so you got
that going on I was thinking about you
know running that what riff would um
what'd you call it on bottom tree still
I'm calling out this thing has so many
support things you can do you know I'm
saying he's got the arc souls then he
someone's got the loominator you shoot
that person you given that person above
you keep getting rifts all day because
that class up once you have more people
around you your if energy starts to go
up so many things man it's just the the
builds in my head I cannot wait to start
putting a lot of this stuff to test man
it is it's gonna be fun it's gonna be
fine I love when they get into this type
of soul now which is like RPG mechanics
yeah so and that was the thing you said
it right just like when you talk to the
Bungie devs they're like and even if you
were like teasing about hey this or that
and I like and I'll even say it too
because I know that can't seem like I
know you can't say anything and I like I
know but they're just like they're like
chomping at the bit to actually say what
they want to but that was one of the
biggest thing when it came to the
viaduct was that tone and we talked
about it before when Mark and Luke came
on that's what I say to a lot of us like
the tone it feels like and a couple of
them really confirmed is like their
feeling of like their their passion
their like they're almost like
re-energized like it was from the top to
the bottom in that studio forever but I
talked to feels that way about what is
to come what they're working on it's
their baby it's what they want to make
it now all of those things are what we
get to look forward to so oh man I can't
wait for all that stuff hi man am i it
futures brightest is we gotta say it is
he you know listen you know I haven't
been the biggest fan of the Annual Pass
I will say that but we're at another
peak right now you know I feel we're at
a nice little peak coming into shadow
just kind of reminds me of a better
version of the war mine because people
don't get warm on a lot of credit I
always feel wore mine was to start off
the turnaround and if it wasn't a
catalyst which were big - exactly bro
III I don't feel water my gets enough
credit for the turn around the start of
the turn and I'll see you know forsaking
is that's just the big fraction it's the
big one but um yeah they want a good
thing man I mean this is great great
great content and um opulence has been
so far tremendous success so fights it's
early we still in the middle of it you
know but um leaps I mean light years I
had a a joker as Wow I mean to meet I
was like wanted lower points but um it's
good stuff it's good stuff they
I cannot wait you know to see when we
roll in to the keep and see how that the
moon toxins continue it's all just I had
to hit Arras talk that crazy talk only
here so cool too but like her process to
get into that voice have you ever seen
her like Walker so when she can probably
do it now but just to walk herself into
that character is definitely interesting
so so so yeah attributes all cool we do
have the solstice of heroes
coming up that'll be at the end of the
month that's on the 30th so some of the
tribute hall and then some of the
moments of triumph are linked to the
sauces of hero so you can't finish all
that stuff up tribute hall separate
sorry moments of triumph it's what I'm
talking about right yep moments of
triumph shirt so as you guys are working
on triumphs whatever it takes to unlock
them you get emblems you get sparrows
you get ships I think I got those this
shirt I'm close to so close to some not
quite all but the shirt looks cool I'm
sure I like the color
yeah it's like they they have even a
graphic of like the guy who put the
graphic together on it and you can
shoulder patch for your emblem and stuff
on the side so moment subtract burger to
be cool probably have to do a little bit
of everything I do have to be crown of
sorrow that I still haven't done yeah
sign me up when you're doing these raise
aid you on breathe I am present because
I need to be a part of all the raid and
all the redness yes I got a star trained
on PC I've been slacking so please
whenever there are raids happening now i
legit boy fair point
oh yeah solstice of heroes that will
we'll get info about that on the 24th
because i think it starts the 30th if i
remember correctly and then Bungie store
has quite a bit of new stuff shirt
shadow keep sure they were all wearing
the shadow keep shirt and it was like
where do you get that and then as soon
as on Bungie day I was like I I see what
you did there
jelly yeah we had a patch obviously on
Tuesday biggest piece of the patch was
the menagerie chest glitch no longer
there and I wanted to shout out senator
age that
like he has opinions about oh he can
talk at some point look hopefully we can
get that man on here so we can all get a
little but like when it comes to and he
actually had kind of a good point is
manager is still one of the most direct
reward paths in the game if you want yes
Belov it I can still go do that and I
still have to deal with the rolls but at
least I know I'm going after that I can
go after a certain piece of armor
certain weapons like one of the cool
things for leveling the menagerie helped
with was like okay my class item right
now is slacking I have three powerful
roles let me go fill that slot real
quick and boost the grind a little bit
more like that was one of the probably
the biggest things a way to do that
seems huge but mm-hmm
what he actually was saying is like now
I can go into menagerie and work on like
hey I can go on this specific grinder
this what that does to the other content
we have basically takes menagerie and
either knocks that stuff down and moves
menagerie up it makes the other stuff
like hey I want to go get the DFA hand
cannon
I have no like guarantee to grind that
thing out but it's like or to get a roll
what so like skeleton keys aren't there
so changing up like night rolls or
reckoning and gambit prime and the
weapons in there like just a mess to
grind for and those are all things
they've learned from but it's like as
good as menagerie is even without
multiple poles great makes other things
look even worse so I was just curious as
you were like hey you've been leveling
up your character this you know recently
trying to max out and stuff like that
and while you have a lot of stuff to do
tons like and you'd like you'll
eventually just get some drops if there
if you ever do want specific grinds or
any things like that how do you feel
like even kept like compared to
menagerie like do you feel the rest of
the game is like kind of like struggling
to be like hey it's all just like
goodness like where do you think things
compare at this point that like because
I mean his basic idea is like a lot of
like leveling systems in the game
whether it's night falls or strikes need
it and they've actually talked about
that so I don't know but they got a lot
of love but those are even worse like
what do you feel balanced in the game
like for a menagerie it's like direct
path like I want to go straight for
beloved versus I'm
go run a strike and get a purple
god-knows-what late right where do you
feel like things are at currently right
now and what would you like to see more
shadow keep is kind of a change like any
one or two major pieces that you'd like
to see tweaked for leveling kind of
direct things or paths or skeleton key
chests all that time yeah I think
they've been on the right direction with
um since armory
when armory hate and then you have your
um you know your choice you want the
poles you want this you want that you
pick your friend you grind you gonna so
I think that was the start of it and he
I mean as I'm incorrect like the you
could tell the other stuff is just
antiquated systems of first of all I'm
not grounded for any of that because
number one all those weapons have like
the old trades and lock there's no
random roles on it you made a fantastic
point about skeleton keys you know I'm
saying like those need to come back in
the worst way so that you can guarantee
that investment right because if you
grind it for that excuse me if you grind
it for that you definitely want that
guarantee drop and that's what menagerie
is doing so yeah I mean it's things that
I think they're on see once I see
improvement I'm fine they're on the path
what they need to do is the older stuff
needs to be brought into those systems
that's where they shrug off and clean
yeah it's like you got Leviathan armor
and all this other stuff right this
stuff should be brought up into again we
talked about it at nauseam older weapons
older armor with you know a little bit
where they don't have all the nodes in
them and you look at them you're like
what am I gonna use this right yeah I'm
not like yeah like silicon neuroma from
the pyramid and it's a sniper but you
don't even have the same number of perks
on it can't get it with random roles and
that happens for basically every
nightfall strike weapon is the same damn
way like ya know I listen trust me I've
been saying this for a long time the
only reason why I have easy on them so
I'm taking some advice from my man II
it's not the holiday you can only do so
much
they've got shadow keep coming and we
understand resources must be allocate
pulled off if they're gonna do these
things this is reasonable this is the
best role in ever just setting that ball
up on the trees and as I'd knock it out
about the post that I saw yesterday it's
that it's the reddit post that we were
actually both read it to you and you're
like I'm reading it so love when it
comes to quality of life and then the
type of stuff you're talking about so I
don't know when to pick my battles like
I was like on that like for that article
if you guys haven't seen it out there
I'll post it and twitch chat right now
but basically what it is it is
somebody's asking about like how are we
doing on housecleaning and quality of
life things and damage or Dylan replying
talking about like quality of life and
where teams can spend their time and I
wanted to see like so for you and as
like if that's something you see is like
they talk about the mercury sparrow
versus other stuff like okay so what do
you care about having versus not having
and when you come to a limited amount of
like bandwidth for like all of the
development team what are your like
prior what do you want to see fixed if
you had to pick like an order for like
one two and three like obviously a
sparrow and Mercury I don't give a crap
like right versus other things like what
do you what do you want to see what are
your big fixes that you want this is my
thing right now and I'm a surprise you
I will forego all of that and as you
know I'm quality of life I know where
you're not vendor refre I don't know but
where I'm going is this shadow keep must
be a success shadow keep is critical
because now we're brand cross safe with
getting people to dust off destiny
because they're gonna be able to play it
when they want and where they want right
so and we introduced in stadia and we're
introducing redacted which we don't know
what is oh yeah yeah there's another
it's cross save and then there's
redacted I don't know what redact it is
where did I see that go to the table is
that is at the very end of the 12 is
that was yeah they say I blew my mom
like what are they talking about so I
was like I didn't realize here we go yep
and then it
yeah boy Christmas parade himself redact
I don't have the foggiest idea yes so
completely are hitting chunky part from
cross save to mmm
we're on sync destroy eliminate bugs I'm
wondering let's just like shadow keeper
future expansions are you thinking it's
like cross play I'm not gonna go to here
I don't think his cross play what do you
think that means then oh this is all one
because there's something cool like this
you're like is this your T word that you
don't okay you know I get about trials I
am T worry you don't say the word don't
eat words listen you know obviously we
don't because names you don't speak his
name you know but um you know I look at
this kind of stuff and they got stuff
cooking I come back from Guardian con
I've had the conversations I've had I've
asked the tough questions you know I'm
saying you can see them bursting at the
scene one ting to elaborate more and
they can't so when I see that kind of
stuff I say stuff is cooking good stuff
is cooking we'll have the Queen on next
week who heads back from the Sun who
probably can't stay and say anything
there's a Myers but but she can allude
to excitement levels she can allude cuz
put it this way remember um forsaken
summit yeah and even though the dados
and the damn caches they couldn't say I
remember em taxi I'm telling you you
guys are gonna be so crazy with this new
thing thing thing and everybody then
that one of them ended up being gambit
the other one you know say I'm just very
cool things I think they're sitting on
some cool stuff and my mentality right
now you know I wasn't just you know all
the old armor need to be brought up
skeleton key all the od1 qol stuff that
we loved is glaringly missing right
glaringly and in this case I'm put a
little artists gonna give them slack to
not bother them for that you worry about
shadow keep you keep the Train
move you got a feeling you got Dover
hold on see this that is where you gotta
give me credit
he's with the quinn the content is good
when you put out good content like an
opulence
you're allowed this see what happens
when you when you put out good content
you just don't drip feed us crap you
give us strong content that we lacking
it we're engaged we give you the longest
you go ahead cleansing this menagerie so
good oh you gave me juju disagree oh
shoot last ah like I'm in a good place
right now
that's all I gotta do they keep that up
you won't hear a peep out of me
but now I think I think there's really
some special happen to show honesty true
I really do I think of something cooking
what what he where's your mindset with
lonel wit you don't say no to rage where
you and that's kind of one of those two
is when he talks about everything even
things like you know like rave rewards
and bling leveling and stuff like that
you've got like heroic menagerie as soon
as we hit the triumph or you beat the
boss like what is the point of really
like bashing your head against crazy
modifiers when the rewards are yeah you
get a chance at a sword but okay that
was mostly it once you get the catalyst
especially for izanagi's burden then you
really probably don't have too much used
to go in there mmm so yeah yeah yeah
cuz I wouldn't want to come with you cuz
dizzy you read my mind bro you said I
need story stuff legit stuff I spoke to
mrs. rain herself keep gonna if I'm
saying the wrong name like six times
then I'm just making it worse listen
she'll see there's my heart here's the
thing you know story is critical and
which I talked about one of the things I
talked her adds and length and I was
like look well you guys knocked it out
the park where they taking king with a
forsaken campaign the strikes did the
missions that narrative Lee led you to
the raid where the raid happens and now
it's a continuation of said story
beautifully done we cannot do situations
where you have you know I don't want to
throw either world
or anything like that but when you have
these one-off raids or these one-off
situations with you know exactly Z Z
don't you dare do that
arbitrary of a raid is any other random
ones
did you see Game Informer's article get
that trash out together former God The
Game Informer
those are my dudes hello this was number
one on their level that was garbage
ball one there's only two rage you can
say to me Kings I won't slash you if you
say is over it's only hit but here's
where they this is where they completely
disqualify themselves yes they had Kings
for number one okay fine you want to
rage raid who a tough boss I'm with you
bro I won't fight you I won't fight you
but they had the nerve the audacity the
unmitigated gall to have wrath of the
machine over both last wish and Volta
grass fire your staff fire you do not
understand what rays are and I love
racing machine right the machine is a
fun rave but how dare you game how did
you put that over those two raids so
that that's it and I really had to bring
that up just to get I know yet this is
the button push this is the we did it
you did it wonderfully yeah so again any
one of these three last wish fall
Kingsville you got him in any order [ __ ]
won't bother you will but you start
throwing that other stuff there over
those threw over those three there we
got a problem
but back to that that point which is
that the whole narrative thing you know
um we just we just gotta have a reason
you know I we need those bits and
another thing with drift the drop the
bull is they set us up in the beginning
right it's gonna be wanting cinematic
and then one more at the end and you're
just like are you really over here just
like tapping your fingers like exactly
it's like you can't do that man like
again
like they've got to do it a surprise
especially there's no strikes in that
one there wasn't rain in that one
so narrative Lee we cannot forget those
things so I am feeling confident though
about shadow keep heiresses back hi
that's like okay so let me ask this all
right will you take something like a
season of The Drifter foreshadow keep
when you mean take as if you will you
accept the they a smaller non-white
season is like hey a smaller team
focused to get something like shadow
keep that we now know I'm and I'm asking
because that's what that could possibly
be like guess what no guess with you
know this is cool thing right out right
now it's called season opulence you see
how great it is yeah and you know
another team that was a part of making
that not Bungie and they don't have that
team anymore that's awesome you know why
I hit it I hit but I saw also store you
know goo stadium back the truck up
mostly things and I saw some other
movements and Shake in there so I just
I'm just saying being at the level is
here and we were here without feelings
baby we're here let's maintain it
let's not accept mediocrity let's not do
that we're gonna keep the level right
here no excuse and put it this way I'm
even there willing to accept this and
you take your time with vendor refresh
stuff I really want badly you know I
want that stuff badly I want I want
shout to dizzy if he's still in the chat
you know how bad I want faction rally
right now ever since I came to PC I
don't have my new monarchy shaders I'm
feeling away all right so again that's
something that I will take all of that
stuff just give me the level of quality
give me the story stuff and then you
could backfill it and take your time and
you won't hear nothing out of me telling
you bro that's all I gotta do yeah to
bring on my faction and Disney's got a
point is like when you time gates Ori
stuff it is it feels weird if you're
gonna time great gate a quest like hey
here's this then you got to do something
to shatter your unlike that's a one
thing we're like a quest is like there's
different steps you may need to do but
if it's like if it's a story you want to
experience
it's like reading a book I'm not gonna
read like chapter 1 set it down for a
week next week yeah like those are and
that's why the the allegiance quests for
the seat of The Drifter and the Vanguard
those were like you could burn through
him pretty quickly kind of get the
little tidbits of voiceover but you got
a little bit more out of them and they
were straight through you say and there
was that it was the nine and those were
I I'm guessing they probably got a lot
of crap feedback for that because it was
and then they set the bar with the
cinematic we're like cool and then it's
like then even just that hype was like
dropped or like is it this week is it
this week is it this week like there was
little tidbits of story in there but man
breaking it up over weeks is that's when
we that's when you know there was some
some issue of like too many people were
working on other things whatever
happened with like season The Drifter
there was a that was the one where was
like this season okay so I guess there's
a question mm-hmm say that's all they
legitimately couldn't put out for that
season whether people are working on six
different other things would you rather
have nothing versus mediocrity I mean
this is a hypothetical I know but it's
like they've talked enough about
capacity and things like that I'm trying
to see for you is like so it was like if
what if they just added like gambit
Prime and then it was like it's a quiet
season not what if not every season
isn't season of opulence because they
had helped with that one they had helped
the you know how do you what they're not
settle and get something better farther
away that's what I'm trying to ask for
what you mean like as far as just like
wait well I mean like timing of future
seasons would you'd rather have it be go
go to a to go to a two season go ahead
set it a freakin okay so that's what I'm
saying so you'll wait longer it's a
letter yeah okay that's what I was gonna
get out yeah absolutely because my thing
is less no disrespect to the team you
know they could have missed us with
drifter let's be honest perfect world
you we we can eliminate drifter out of
the equation it sounded cool when we
heard about it but when we got to the
actual function of gamma crime link to
reckoning you know and I'm saying
no raid you know sometimes it was just
content for the sake of content and
that's the only thing I was worried
about with the Annual Pass set up which
is three because I was like wow that's
ambitious they never really do stuff in
a cyber landing the same thing next year
right and I'm like I'll be on it's like
that's where I'm with you and that's
what that's the one point I was trying
to get around yeah I'm willing to
sacrifice that third one I'm willing to
go back to kind of drought broke if data
gave us look like if we had if it was
horrible not only if we had a better
Ford with a little better story you know
I'm saying some strikes some vendor
refreshes yours a and some you know like
throw that could have held a little bit
and then had that for the summer
I'm cool with the Miss in the March or
whatever it may be you know me so I just
it just comes down to I don't want them
to be so concerned of hitting a gate yes
and and having to have to make content
I'm cool with the old way of the gap as
long as the quality is there but what
I'm going to say even though you're
clapping very loudly like your plan
no let you go to phase here we go but
that's like I am with you on that
because like that's what I was like if
there's your overall point I know but
that's like even if say it's like it was
to say it's in January and a winded
opulence launched June July if it's just
January and just June so it's like
trimester is instead of quarters but you
know what's he's saying right now we're
literally seeing the expansion format we
used to be see that's all like if little
links they could say it seasons but you
know if they do that it'll be expansions
again but I think they're very clear
based on that meeting we went to seasons
I'm sorry you hate I hate you I hate the
hair this did seasons I had a stay now
they are not going away this is their
new thing so it just they have to find
that balance and it's gonna be tough if
I'm worried about them with that respect
cuz I'm going to do a three again you
know yeah they're getting better but
I don't know I'm gonna that's the only
thing I'm not worried about shadow keep
I'm worried about post shadow keep fair
what happens in dissemble what happens
and that much how beefy are those how
you know gotta see I mean you got me you
got me a saying it's like one thing the
annual pass has given us
it's like replayable you have so many
different things to do now I mean you've
been playing for giuse you can go after
those weapons now
reckoning leads like yeah right
Oh God throw it's a bucket move
everything around pull it back out bake
it again it needs and the whole like
sets and stuff like that yeah reckoning
is wolf yeah I don't like we told him
toad we talked we had a good
conversation with Penn oh mama like and
that was like we both say like four I'm
split there's parts of both that I like
and I think you were more unregulated
bro I'm gonna tell you right now as to
you again shelter that cooking thing
shoutout it's something you know what it
is I've been playing I put that on again
but this week right regular game and I
play game a prior cuz I wanted to get
all my gaming stuff done I'm knocking
about there's something about regular
gambit that just is it is that it is
just it's just more fun and less I feel
stressed through crime I feel like it's
trying to be the trials of gambit but
it's not really doing it you know say
like it's just it's something still I
don't know what I'd I really can't put
my finger on it except that when I
played I could just tell you how I felt
clang about six to eight matches each of
each one and gambit regular gambit to me
felt fun and then the other thing would
again with the whole the suits thing
because you just i have no incentive to
just play one mold footed and grab a
bunch of clothes for one month and
that's that was my big thing about no
it's true
like the set bonus perks only being
usable in prize no perks anywhere else
like no like not even making reckoning
easier was like a big thing in me
because I'm working in reckoning to get
these drops
and the drops that I get don't make this
activity any better it doesn't even say
like in reckoning or in the realm of the
emissary like even in the realm of the
emissary you do more damage and have
more like make your progress as you go
through like build so then when you get
to 6 90s and all that insanity it's like
you are stronger in that activity
because you put time into it and that's
one thing when it comes back to raids
hurts that actually like on trade
specific perks on armor I want weapons
that are truly unique to the raid so
there's a reason to grind them out not
just outlaw rampage themed last wish or
outlaw rampage themed crown of Sorrows
like outside of the exotics we do like
perks for me have got to be something
that comes Oh they've got what happened
to like stand on a callus plates and get
faster reload speed or you know those
classic Kings fall those classic how no
or armor when you're in the Shadow Realm
when you're running the orb in North
yeah hey dude I've got the armor I'm
gonna be running it and that makes you
stronger they're like I remember Wrath
and having this suit you do you know
take more damage whenever I'm sorry I
thought wrath wrath was trash what
listen wrath is late but let's not get
ridiculous fun it's probably one of my
most fun rays I was like it had some
really unique weapons it had they had
the double chest system I will say this
from the challenges and stuff I will say
this I will give you all always give
wrath this wrath is one of the most fun
and one of the most rewarding raids ever
as far as pure rewards wrap you I will
definitely say it it like it had ever
got two double chests thing it had it
had a thing where remember you just run
the raid and you'd get the little see
the key fragment ease so just about
running it consistently it was really
cool and I'm saying but um you know as
far as the raid itself go there you
didn't like the wrath raid no I love the
wrath rating these levels to this
product there's like there's there's a
great movie and then there's like the
infinity war something like that was
like
spider-man homecoming uh it was good it
was strong it was like you know a good
movie but then you got like infinity
wool
you're like you've got in-game like
you're just stuck on the vault installed
and you will be forever so it's all you
can you just was a baby you didn't
understand what's going that's what yeah
it was my first raid well that well
that's one problem but but it's not a
problem I just have lighter experience
on that yeah and I get that that's cool
all I'm saying is the Ray for what you
did here we go you know poke was like it
did for what the vault has done weapons
rewards bosses the only knock you can
say yeah oh my god didn't have all this
tremendous narrative it was the very
first one can we cut it some slack like
it was the first one right okay yeah
last wish they got to look at what vault
did okay let's make a story taking got a
look at what voltage okay let's do this
but we are not going to disrespect it
but I'll give those two if you like
those other two ahead [ __ ] Julian
putting raffle
Isaac incur a higher on the list than
some Father forgive him he bought us of
sound state in mind too much rate talk
we've never thought that was always
great just she had the fancy Gentiles
also - yeah they were going through like
ranking the newer ones basically it was
just cool they had fun at that piece so
excuse me child the mission 91 rash was
good not the best
I agree access accounts a pretty random
and chaotic for me listen I like the
accident do um they did reuse a boss in
Wrath weeing ongoing gonna to that foot
saying do at the beginning before him
with the TVs again same dude
siege was fun now Alex each 32 bosses
involved moving on disrespected Gorgona
The Gargoyle Gorgons did a little I'll
owe ya your bosses that's amazed that's
the boss so we gonna act like Leviathan
ain't have the door so we go we go
that's we subtracting points on the
bottom
I'm not even provided by a drag I like
my by them but again like issue okay it
and that's I guess the theme where
people give raids crap and I think I
respect Bungie you can rank him however
you want and that's totally like
opinions preferences experiences first
last all that stuff's different I
respect them for truly actually stepping
outside the box for trying different
things and making themed raids for like
Leviathan it was those games and the
pool yes you have like it I respect
Kuroda because you have the animalistic
frantic nature of the hive and they fit
the theme especially the opening
encounter of crota is still one of the
best I think yeah see dissing we don't
wait let me tell you something funny now
I'm gonna use just same logic against
you
what because the way I feel about um
vault and you say like we got the
nostalgia it was the first woman I feel
like crowed is so overrated like I don't
I've never had it could I think that was
your first rape so I'm like alright
dropping a ball and I mean well a lot of
people they'll a lot of people love crow
right and I'm just like it's very
overrated to me it was like okay drop
into the hole you move like molasses to
rooms like I'm like okay like the best
part is the music in the the heroic
aspect of the sword and everyone get in
the corner and shoot you Gjallarhorn
okay cool
I just I listen I get it for you guys
they like to be heroes I think that's
why you guys like this rate you'll of
the heroic moments you love the
atmosphere of going into the Hellmouth
or not I get that but if I look at that
raid as a it just it it does not resume
it with me it on any level like outside
of the weapons the weapons to me
was what saved that raid for me like I
really didn't like that rate and it's
mad short but that's me Jack call me the
rose-colored glasses no I mean and
that's kind of one of those is like but
still they have tried and done a very
good job of thematic grades and I've
enjoyed like I'm at Leviathan you take a
raid where you have like one boss empty
they got crap for that but you have
different encounters that are like
you're in the baths and you have bathers
coming out your eyes and that stuff you
have the dogs in the garden yes and you
have a gut which is this show and like
yes that was the I mean Leviathan like
has its whatever but mm-hmm
the fact that like you take people who
have World of Warcraft background so
your bosses with like 10 raids there's a
long boss the boss and adds in between
and you go over a thematic slate it has
a yeah that's why I like it and you know
what other thing that Leviathan doesn't
get enough credit for I know I'm not not
against it is the bosses but you know
what's dope the underbelly connected bro
like they literally did something very
cool and I thought the little twist with
the boss was kind of cool do you like oh
you thought you beat them in your lair
it's like now you still have killing man
with the glass you shoot the glass off
the thing and they come on we go
the opulence I like Leviathan like I
really do you know and real quick cuz
I'm not getting the crota haters are
coming from you right so um listen the
coral lovers excuse me um you got me no
I give it up but he said come on pick up
the sword and the epic hero music of
crota absolutely quota opening and me I
don't I'm not which I'll on the opening
part just the part with the dropping
down and the screaming okay if it did
not your socks off like the same way you
guys get excited about that last point
I'll give it to you know I get excited
about when vault started you may laugh
at this right I get excited was I know
everybody's standing on the plate and
then we building the spire to get inside
did you I think that wasn't me I was
like oh my god I've never seen anything
like for you you probably laugh about
this the silliest thing I was blown we
work against 3t okay
let me let me point that as a point of
reference how many times in desti one
before you got to that raid as you went
through the missions had you stood and
waited for something to get activated
while you defend a point that time was
not a new mechanic how many times you
like hey go sit over here and do these
things and then six people doing that in
no activity I understand the difference
between it but I'm just saying like the
mechanics of when you start crota as you
go down you're like you're slowed down
you have to landings slowed you out it
was no mechanic it would just throw a
whole bunch of of hyphenated the low
dudes and run at you while you move at
two frames per second that was the
mechanic that was just so crazy about
and you got a little red thing over your
head in his dark woo mechanics like all
I'm saying is three people three groups
of two or whatever it is you split up
was more exciting for me we're all here
you go
whereas you blow on me I'm moving at 2
frames per second in the dark and you
think that's the greatest thing ever I
just we just will always disagreed with
that rate I don't know what it is with
you guys with that rainbow me the krona
does absolutely not like they could have
eliminated crowd have been fine if you
didn't have kurta you wouldn't have
Kings fall true we had to kill the Sun
to get the real get the real rain yeah
well Kings fall was better than yeah
both of those so that's fine yeah it's
like honestly like they've done a great
job with raids but I will definitely say
the ones that have a story theme tied to
them always give you more connection to
what's going on like when you go through
the regicide mission you have the sword
there then you go in then you see giant
ass orcs in the end you're like I killed
him but holy crap you like those even
like just one story mission to the final
raid boss that connection was huge in
King's phone that's why one of the
reasons it's towards it is like it stops
oh and last wish like you hear about
Riven it's talking about you
through your like falling and seeing
like the scale of this giant ahamkara
dragon it's just like those pieces are
amazing so brochure ochi may even cali
with the everybody got to pick a little
hotel room you get is like yeah I was
like I like the gevalt is once you get
it it's easy but man people who figured
out the first day god that had to be
rough but generally it's like yeah Cali
and sorrow and then swagger off then you
have been Riven with your like muted
right now man I'm still muted can you
just I couldn't hear you yeah you
weren't dogger volume something yep yeah
it was a little weird yeah I just I I
think last wish is just man I mean that
is something else and again it had the
story too you know and saying nasty
that's nothing but makes Kings fall raid
just that
orcs is one of the most the greatest
bosses out you know I'm saying shout out
to Brian Marcus with that artwork don't
look at that oh forget it real quick get
in real quick show to people show to
people what it is that is amazing it
literally shows the true scale of how
people look at the guardians in the Lord
corner in relation to how big Oryx is
that's a boss that's a boss and all Jews
just talking that talk to you know they
say yeah that's what anyone says King
for all their greatest I won't fight
them I won't find him is is that's just
a a preference thing you know I'm saying
that's just what you like from your
raids and I won't find anybody like that
Ray was truly that was a hardcore a that
was a man's raid but yo you do you think
about it yeah when someone asked you to
do Kings fall come on you gotta be PC
that was a person's raid come on that's
a Guardians ring damn it so it's like
play some hair on your chest or your
legs I don't know
so as one of them digs we're like you
you never forget who you did it with
what how you accomplished it and you
knew it was a time commitment right you
like oh man we're talking four all right
how many time I got about two hours at a
Lascar you gotta you gotta buckle up you
got strapped your boots on that's what
it was great game they've come a long
way yeah trying to think of where will
this topic even started I don't I don't
know we just got into it I got off on
dice this is radiant cell this is like a
flash boil 0.0 throw back always next
week will for sure be long so I was
gonna talk about say a guardian Cod next
year if you haven't got your tickets
watch for the hotel blocks if you can
stay in there and do it like patch bad
you do tribute hall quality life yeah we
had a lot of them so what else were you
in this past week how are you how is how
you settling back in doing good yeah as
far as like just destiny in general
that's new like yeah as you kind of get
back in you've been playing more how's
it feel just to be like kind of [ __ ]
in it's got us hooks in right now and
Bros is when destiny is good it's the
gift and the curse it's like when it's
good nothing else exists nothing else
exists bro you just sit there and I'm
just blown away like four or five hours
in it's like I still got so much to do
like four or five hours you invest and
you like man I just put a small dent in
my list of accomplishments oh one thing
I got a complaint I've been me I've been
hold on this week's not the carboxy we
talk about it every time we play so we
got to get this pursuit thing
straightened out I ride nuts I hate the
extra step the extra click the lack of
organization please if we're gonna do
something like this
shout out to my to our team you know I
got love for y'all know your plate is
full but we've got to do something about
this pursuit tab it is ah it is
cumbersome it's just cumbersome like
just for me to keep track and then if we
know if we're gonna do that right you
know how you contract some of them baby
can we increase
the amount we can track uh something cuz
I just hate hitting two buttons in two
good and two clicks - you're going to a
submenu to find out what milestone and
what it is such a mess and I just want
to know what I want to do next
it's literally planning like one thing
about destiny especially a guy like me
who doesn't have a lot of time right
Matt time management is critical for me
I need to go know how long I'm gonna
play what I'm gonna do how long I'm
gonna do and where I'm gonna attack for
us if I gotta spend 20 minutes in the
menus just to figure out the progress on
this and and then the triumph is that
how much is the mountaintop grenade
things I got where's this one tied to
that and why is it not on the actual arm
you know shout to them crucible joints
right you know what I'm talking about
when you get the crucible pinnacle
weapon you you look you think you have
the bounty in your purse ooh and then it
says oh you complete this by doing
ascend the mountain where does ascend
the mountain there where is that as an
accident like that's them learning over
seasons cuz those haven't been the same
because you had one of them that was
just like progress in one place that
when you finished it you got you were
able to like click the triumph the next
one that progress is tracked in the
triumph because he had to get fabled for
another one like this time it's all
within the pursuit bounty which is you
know it's tracked across all characters
but you have to pick it up on every
character well it's like just yeah
consistently somehow the bounty triumphs
pursued account level quests just please
fix that shadow keys mess like I know
they wanted to try something different
whether it was like whether it was the
in the inventory tab and there's too
much things loaded so they wanted to
give you more spots like I was even say
you're talking to one of the bunch you
guys asking about the vault mm-hmm and
like if you have like 500 slots was like
you load all 500 yeah because they got
to be able to look at them or if it
takes longer and load every page then
when you load you'll have that delay and
they're going stuff from like a base ps4
with a spinning hard drive yeah versus
people with like PC and SSDs and they
they have to program for all of them and
that's the point to where that's that's
yeah they have to go for that and that's
why I like the newer consoles and maybe
a destiny 3 like those of those points
as we talked about whether it's 2021
whether it's 2020 whether it's 2022 like
those are the bigger fix of dedicated
servers like those of The Bling those
are the big asks and big changes that
like moving pursuits from one place to
another or moving vault space from here
it's like yeah this is gonna be working
on like I was talking a lot of them and
they were like I was so happy when we
got rid of last gen consoles you know
like performance testing and stuff like
that to try and balance and work with
the ps3 cel-shading oh my god Leigh it's
awful so there were yeah there are
evolutions of this game so I'm just
taking longer than others so mmm
absolutely absolutely that's what we're
hoping on it one thing about September
though that I have confidence much as
I'm complaining is the September DLCs
always attacked qol historically
historically forsaken like they always
introduced better streamlining and cure
so I think we're gonna get a couple of
those things and honestly that in PvP
loves and just fixing on a big you know
fix up the house give us you know some
better things to do and just
organization hahaha I like this so yeah
if they do that we're on the right track
with all the right track
yeah well we have eclipse the two-hour
mark to no surprise Guardian con was an
hour in and of itself yes but yeah bad
juju is out there if you haven't touched
the tribute hall if you want to do the
cheese go look it up that's up to you
but if you want to save your materials
it's very efficient September is going
to end all gamers lives yeah all the
games or lads
Monster Hunter Borderlands which I got
to play as well that was that Guardian
con and that's one of the reasons for
the name change because it was guarding
time but Borderlands 3 is sitting there
they had control in the backend control
a tobacco the other so I was like gaming
community Expo
just but they do say gaming community
that's a nice way they phrase that I
like kind of how they do like that um
but September is stupid
September is so broken of a month like I
don't even under I'm gonna I'm trying to
figure out if I can get enough destiny
stuff done but I could potentially like
stream some Monster Hunter and get ready
for like ice-born mm-hmm play that for
about a week and a half how much time I
get and then jump destiny cuz I don't
think I'm gonna be able to squeeze
Borderlands 3 in there I don't think
it's gonna happen because I mean it's
destiny and destiny for me as number one
priority
so what do you think even with that
little what is it four days four days
for Borderlands does not feel like
enough like especially if you're like oh
my friends want to go do something that
weekend and I work like that's one of
the four day and then I'm done like like
so you have both no no no exactly when
you both know that destiny is going to
be Petty and they're gonna put some most
stupid low quests or some other every
week you know destiny has shown their
petty during this division situation
during they have managed to get some
beloved weapon or say that's just
marketing it's great market oh yeah
there will probably be well I that's
actually one of the things I missed from
taking King was when the taken started
to invade and they were out kind of on
the planets and you said like they I
don't feel like they've really done that
level of something yeah and like if the
moons haunted like what if I don't know
I still would love for them to
occasionally just mix planets up I wanna
see like the hive roaming around on oh I
don't know etz maybe they're in a place
they shouldn't be or you know you have
cabal on Titan for example just I'd love
to randomly just like log in and stuff's
just like everybody flipped the script
and everybody's just like moved around
that'd be just kind of a fun thing
occasionally like I'm gonna go do
bounties what the hell are you doing
here fun way to mix it up but yeah
that's that week before quests
especially with the timing of everything
around there they're gonna want to like
start the hooks and then that's kind of
where I wonder when it comes to and they
have their first steam community article
out
I saw Cosmo put his first steam article
up he's like not there Lulu they're
gonna have to transfer over to steam
which there yeah I think it's all from
the API so you're just going to link
accounts I'm sure um and then when it
comes to like the new light players I
know they say September 17th what if
they're like by the way new lights free
like a week early to let people kind of
get into it and get ready you know it
you know it's gonna be they're gonna
start doing some stuff where the moon's
accessible you know how they do it again
taste of the new content a week before
remember it was on rise of iron and it
was like um there was deceive a thing
going around you know people had to see
the stuff around their head and they're
going to do they did like bungees
notorious for this stuff to get the type
train rolling and they give you just a
taste of the new content right before
nobody gave us weapon changes or
something a little bit before - they
gave me always doing that boilers I love
you man but I'm worried where my
pictures come and then we'll have to do
the over-under on the raid it's it six
hours is three days is it 10 days for
and I heard I think was DCP was talking
about raids and like the timing for like
shadow keep I don't want to rush shadow
keep if it's a full expansion if there's
a story if there's Lane quests and new
strikes I want to enjoy that get some
leveling up like the 10 days for last
wish was nice I still wasn't ready for
the raid but I didn't care cuz I wasn't
forced to rush even if I wanted to so
right I want more time on that one in
the fall to give it time well we got a
lot to look forward to we had an awesome
time if you have opinions thoughts about
Guardian con or you just want to go hang
out or you want to meet us out there at
some point be the next year it's gonna
be fun or I got my dick you bought the
ticket already yeah I need in my mind
I'm gonna take I wouldn't play around I
like just in case you get to get too big
let me take care of it geez X event calm
that's right that's right sir
get your
premiere plus now get tickets there you
go ahead and click over here premiere
plus you'll hit one of those for me for
us but a hotel room yeah yeah I'll be
watching that one for sure they usually
now kind of before yeah and squats they
seem to like as long as you're fairly
early you should be okay on the blocks
cuz I mean yeah it's not everybody's
like jumping on though some people did
like Airbnb ease and stuff like that
like it's not a bad thing if you got a
group so it just kind of depends on but
honestly like if it's your first if it's
like you're like not sure and want to go
stay at the hotel if like if it works
because man everything is there you
don't have to go anywhere you can you
can get it over to the resort spend the
whole time at the con uber back to the
airport and never have to move never
have arrived and won't go anywhere
no way so do love it man and those rooms
at night oh yeah
they were nice cozy gets done well it is
almost two and a half not quite but we
are definitely moving up I know you're
tired sound of crash but thank you guys
episode 65 a success so next week same
time same bat Channel we will have the
Red Queen we will be promoting that one
I'll get her links and info and stuff up
kind of as soon as I can from her so
that wouldn't be looking forward to you
guys know you can always find this on
your audio platforms the one we did
before we left we hit like one hundred
and ninety some odd views with full guy
almost two hundred so slow the audio is
growing so thank you guys cool yeah it
was awesome again shout out to being
just awesome cool guy actually at the
con too good dude
so thank you guys yeah cogniat you wrap
it up let him know what you got coming
you're back in the back in the home
front back in the home front man you
already know home at look Witter and I
love podcasts on YouTube every Sunday is
the Lord's Day 1:00 p.m. Eastern got a
switch up the guest we had look schedule
conflict cuz we're gonna get some
developers in but some things happen
they've had some crunch that they've
experienced and your boy law Cognito
what's very receptive and worked with
the developer in a second what we
reschedule you know you'll make that
concession for your guys so we go switch
it up a little bit and we're gonna bring
back the saltiest gamer he was joined
us in the realm salty is of its families
been a fan of all time his growth as a
content creator has been tremendous a
lot of stuff talked about that Nintendo
switched light and maybe I get some
people to bend the knee we shall see I
saw that so what was the bimini wager
cuz you were going straight for it oh
because basically I predicted that the
switch light would come and it would
come at a lower price point I was told
that there's no way
grandpa Nintendo is gonna discount
anything a little bit be $300 so it came
with a nice small price of $200 exactly
which is which technically I won a bet
but there is no knee I just got a scale
no tell him this y'all they I tried to
get them to bend the knee and commitment
they were scared they would take the bet
so I'm gonna act like I'm taking these
or Sunday that's what I'm doing the
realm of the lords so ii did every sir
they will for you of eastern you already
know I love podcast YouTube please check
out the articles Lords of gaming that
net my man Dizzy's in the chat he is the
editor in chief we've got some
tremendous tremendous articles he's got
one on EA I'll put one up this morning
about all you PC guys rising 3,000
chipset guys no destiny for you wait
wait until the patch comes out check all
that stuff out man it's really cool
Lords of gaming that net we got a lot of
good content everything you know destiny
all the things going on in the council
and in PC whatever you want we got it so
check us out and show us some support
there and Lords gaming net on Twitter as
well so that's all I got and of course
you know the last word where my man is
bond sister resilient and the birthday
boy for years it's been a minute and um
it's good your happy birthday bro I love
doing this show it she was always
hilarious always fun rent talk for hours
no didn't I'm just continue to go but
salute brother and I hope it is a good
one thank you very much and to everybody
out there thank you for being in chat
today we had an awesome home oh you guys
yeah thank you for coming in hanging
with us we know it's a way to start your
day some of you guys can be it work some
you may not be able to talk but listen
or catch it on YouTube or audio later
wherever you listen to us thank you for
letting us for you fill your ear holes
over two hours whoo cuz as always it is
what do you call it log point here bet
Guardian Khan was amazing awesome to
meet you as well
happy to buy you that giant margarita
the size of our heads that was amazing
and just on a bonus out there so again
yeah awesome to see you sir and it's not
gonna be another four years we'll be
back kind of next year now that's gonna
be our annual thing that guy isn't gotta
do it you gotta do it yourself
alright everybody well you know where to
find me it's twitch it's Twitter it's
YouTube it's Eve on ttis everywhere you
guys know where to find me wherever
you're listening Phoebe Ont is I'm the
only one out there if you look that up
you'll find me so thank you guys for
very much episode 65 the last word for
July 12th thank you all and for this
week's episode it has been the last word